tearing down and trashing president
trump isn't enough for the liberal media
they're now targeting his supporters
history's going to look back on this
and i think a lot of people are going to
be embarrassed over time when they look
back and say
how did i do that how did i fall for
that what happened to me what was i
thinking in that time but your
grandchildren your kids will look back
and say ooh what a grandpa did what
do what what did dad do what did mom do
in this moment
and and realize that you were on the
wrong side of history wow
and while the partisan press serves up
softballs to joe biden one republican
who's calling out the glaring double
standard
look you'd have to be a special kind of
stupid not to see the
the disparate treatment between mr biden
and mr trump
journalists can't pick sides uh
otherwise they're they're they're not
seeking out the truth they've got to be
equal opportunity a-holes if you will
and and and too many of our journalists
have started
picking sides oh god god bless senator
kennedy
um juan at the top what lemon said i
don't like this whole idea of social
shaming
you know making people walk the plank
when their guy loses and
and and wearing like a scarlet letter
for the rest of their lives
i think that just divides the country
not a very healthy idea
would you agree no but i don't think
that's what he was doing i think
well well first of all it was my
impression my impression is that what
we're talking about is
you know there's a example you know
dana and i know uh andy card used to be
in the bush white house
you know and andy card uh just wrote a
piece and he said 9 11 commission said
failure to have a smooth transition
after the 2000 election
definitely had impact on what happened
to the country in 9 11 right
and you think about this being a
volatile time
in terms of the coronavirus and the like
you think about
the threat that we face even our
colleague brian kilmeade on fox and
friends said this morning
it's time for this transition to get
going and for the president to cooperate
with the incoming
by the administration now i i think i
agree with brian kilmea that's news
right there typical right
that's news right there but i say yeah
as to as to senator kennedy i believe
we're quoting brian
i'm just telling you because because
this is what i did with you yesterday i
had to cite for you
republican lawyers who say there's
nothing to this john that doesn't work
with me
i i know nothing nothing kennedy what
are your thoughts on all this
i look at don lemon's statement and i i
see a glaring
example of groupthink and i think it's
incredibly dangerous because you have to
think the way we do or you are
wrong and if you are wrong there will be
consequences
and that is the absolute implication
there and
we should all be offended by that our
sensibilities should be
offended by that because we shouldn't be
forced to
look at the same problem in the same way
or look at the same candidate
and have to vote for that person because
a group of people
who thinks better of themselves than
they do of individuals
they're telling you that that you have
to vote for that person
or you're going to wake up with regrets
and
if you look at the issues critically
you're not going to regret them
and i hope to god that the press now
treats every president the way they have
treated president trump
and i hope they do it skeptically and i
hope that they
are aggressive about it and i hope they
hold truth to power
no matter the administration i doubt
they're going to do that
and that is cowardly if you're setting a
new precedent apply it uniformly
if you're not then eat a bag speaking of
waking up every day with regret
greg get a bag of what kennedy
all right um the quote from lemon was
really
he said uh you'd be surprised what
happens to people when they're on their
death beds
and i always have a pretty good uh
principle that when someone's
fantasizing about somebody on their
deathbed
it's not because they like you right he
truly
you know what he is he's the hood
ornament for that type of person
who became everything they supposedly
hated trump about
right so they always accuse trump of
being divisive and evil and
and what happens is no they just they're
just projecting their own
interior hate and pain onto him and you
look at it
you look at uh lemon and that's what he
did every single night
and so what's happening to your point
about groupthink is you're seeing all
these interesting bedfellows in america
where you see
glenn greenwald on tucker you know these
are things that are happening all the
time you see
liberal actual traditional liberals and
conservatives meeting together
it's no longer republicans versus
democrats
red state versus blue blacks versus
whites male versus females
it's america versus the industry that is
creating these conflicts
we're starting to figure this out right
we're saying we're saying as long as you
pit white versus black male versus
female gay versus straight you're
keeping us busy
so we don't look at you so we don't look
at you the media industrial complex
or silicon valley the people that
control the algorithms or the
or the comfy uh political establishment
once we
all of us stop fighting amongst
ourselves we can destroy this whole
thing
that's a good point dana final thought
have you seen uh i'm sure you've seen
um a lot of the analysis over the last
four years but really in the past couple
weeks increasingly is
they um many people i think don lemon is
a part of this because he said it
he just can't believe that there are
actual americans that really believe
this stuff and that
he believes that one day they will
re-examine their life and that they will
come to see that he was right which to
me is like the exact
opposite of the reason you wanted to go
into journalism in the first place
the news media especially print
reporters sent
reporters out across america to try to
understand trump voters and they just
still
they they can't get it yeah but what
they haven't done
is taken a look at the their own
messaging and their own policies
so free college medicare for all
defund the police um cancel culture was
a big like that whole idea
cancel culture president trump i was
going to say bush president trump's
biggest applause line
in 2016 was america has become too
politically correct
and i think that that continued and you
look at some of these republicans that
were able to beat democrats in those
swing districts in the house
i think that had a lot to do with it so
rather than examining
and putting trump voters on the couch to
try to psychoanalyze them
democrats would probably be have time
better spent
thinking about their own messages
because i think they're about to
have their hats handed to them in
georgia that's right